and it was extremely painful and the
doctors just wanted to bombard me with
painkillers and
corticosteroid injections and they were
like you have to have surgery
and you have to wear this really massive
metal back brace welcome to 20 minute
leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lumitec and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford today's solutions for pain
management are
way off welcome celine ivari co-founder
and ceo of holy me
having studied genetics of human disease
celine is well aware of the impact our
environment has on predisposition to
conditions
when her mother's autoimmune condition
flared up as a result of a highly
stressful lifestyle
she made it her mission to help her in
any way she could holy me stems from
this experience
she wanted to revolutionize people's
approach to everyday stresses
aches and pains at holy me they offer
the healthiest most effective solutions
without any compromise on long-term
health
celine ivari thank you for joining me on
20 minute leaders how are you today
i'm well thank you for having me michael
i'm extremely excited to have you and
where are you calling from in the world
right now
i'm in london uk london uk well i'm in
tel aviv so it's a close but far but
you know in this podcast everything is
very close uh celine
you have a very a unique background of
studying
genetics of human disease and following
that
you know really the different
initiatives that you founded up to now
holy me
really revolve around this idea of how
can we you know look at our environment
look at our well-being and
and and and come up with interesting
insights and and actually
actionable items that we can do to to
improve our well-being so i'm excited to
hear about your journey
going all the way back to studying you
know biology and studying
studying these things tell me a little
bit about sort of what you set out to do
and what sparked your even curiosity
into this field
and then we'll transition into your
actual initiatives yeah
sure um so i would have to say that
from a fairly young age i
witnessed that pain management
is mismanaged um
and also grossly misunderstood that's
both from my studies
and from uh personal experiences so
firstly from personal experiences
i personally had a herniated disc in my
lower back
as a teenager i was like 17 and
and it was extremely painful and the
doctors just wanted to bombard me with
painkillers and
corticosteroid injections and they were
like you have to have surgery
and you have to wear this really massive
metal back brace and um thankfully i
didn't listen because i found all that
extremely invasive
uh for such a young age um and then
other than that my my mother who's
literally
she's everything to me she suffered
she has an autoimmune condition which is
inflammatory it's called psoriatic
rheumatoid arthritis and it's extremely
painful
and it can be debilitating and a
few years ago she had a flare-up in this
in this condition
which left her on bed rest and with a
tremendous amount of pain
and i having studied science
being interested in health and having
managed my own pain really took it upon
myself to help my mother in any way i
could
and um and from my studies i was always
into sciences
and i studied genetics of human disease
i'd say the key takeaway from from my
studies
was the eye-opening understanding that
your
genetic predisposition can
be completely altered based on your
environment
and that's an extremely empowering
notion that yes you are born
with a set of genetic conditions
uh predisposition to conditions but the
environment
you live in can switch on or off these
genes
and when you understand that it sort of
gives you
so much more power uh in
you know understanding how to manage
your own health
and um and so i guess
from that i was extremely careful um
from
from my own self to to manage my back my
pains
in a way that's more holistic that
encompasses
all aspects of my life so that i don't
turn to medical solutions for something
that essentially is chronic
uh it's a chronic pain it's not gonna go
away so masking it with pain
killers is only going to make me
suffer the consequences of their side
effects with stomach lining issues etc
and and for my mother it's also it's an
autoimmune condition
it's it has a genetic predisposition and
i knew that
her environment would help either
you know turn off and get back into
remission or at least you know try to
decrease
the necessity for uh medical
intervention as much as possible
and it sounds to me that the the framing
of this and the
you know the the the i guess the the
switches that i said yeah
the nature versus nurture right and the
difference between going through life
and saying you know i'm destined to be
injured so i guess i'll just you know
succumb to it and i'll take whatever
painkillers they give me rather than
saying
well yes i i do have this predisposition
to have that
that have that as an indicator but but i
still have control over to what effect
i'm gonna let it control over me
and there are actually things that i can
do to tackle that into
and to mitigate those consequences
instead instead of just taking those
same painkillers
that are gonna down the line just hurt
me even more exactly
exactly and that's extremely empowering
it's understanding that you have this
genetic code it's a
sequence of dna but over that
you have some kind of cover over your
dna and that's your epigenomics
and that you know can cover
some of your genetic predisposition
switching them off which means some
proteins which would normally bind to
the sequence of dna
and cause a cellular response um
to trigger the phenotype that we see can
be switched off with this cover and this
covers determined by your environment
and what's even more empowering is
understanding that that cover
can also be inherited so the way your
environment
will affect your epigenomics
can be transmitted to your
offspring and so you're not only doing
it for you you're doing it for your
future generations
and i think and i think that's extremely
empowering so tell me a little bit about
how you
take that and take that understanding
that motivation you finish your studies
and
and then you think okay well how can i
actually you know make use of this and
do it in a scalable way that can
actually impact
a lot of people around the world right i
i have to admit
it wasn't like that for me i wasn't i
didn't do my studies thinking
you know i'm going to do a startup et
cetera
and none of that happened i i went on to
work
um in the in the pharmaceutical
companies
um and as a medical educator
and then i went on to join my family
actually my mother and my sisters and
setting up a hair loss clinic
in london called mishkati it was an
extremely
wonderful experience i didn't want to
leave at all and then this
this happened with my mom my mom felt
unwell and it just became my life's
mission to help her in any way i could
just with a more holistic approach
and it's honestly the success of that
approach
that made me think i want to help more
people
it sort of happened organically i
started having people around me
asking for you know the i started
formulating products
based on natural healthy ingredients for
my mother
because i wanted that anti-inflammatory
response
but with none of the side effects or
something that would be soothing
relaxing
more caregiving i mean you start doing a
lot of research on holistic approach to
health and you understand
things that are you know just
the power of touch when you're aching
when you're stressed
um and just different elements and and
pain is not i mean it's really
grossly misunderstood if you're trying
to say
pain is a medical condition or pain it's
a physiological
problem that if you can't see it in an
x-ray
then it's you know not there um that's a
gross misinterpretation you know if you
think of the phantom line syndrome
people
have agony in a leg that they don't have
there's no nerve ending there there's no
bone there's no tissue there's nothing
but the pain is extremely real and then
you know you have people that
have suffered from a car crash and have
a broken arm
they can't even feel that pain is super
complex
and it involves so many different things
um and you know by trying to take this
holistic approach with my mom
letting her take her her medical
treatments but
making sure she's also addressing
you know the sorry um
also addressing the um psychological
aspects that might be related to the
intensity of the pain
you can think of people that have
flare-ups with autoimmune conditions
they're extremely related
to life events you know like suffering
from grief or an extremely stressful
period
will cause a flare-up in your in your
autoimmune conditions
there's so many variants when it comes
to
pain and and i guess
from my experience with my mother
helping her with a more holistic
approach to health from my own personal
experience
and these products that i was
formulating that really encourage
self-care i wanted to bring that to more
people
just really educate explain
that some things are inherent
to our lifestyle stresses aches
pains they're inherent to our lifestyle
you know if you're
sitting and working at a desk all the
time you will
have you know tense neck and shoulders
lower back aches if you're very athletic
and you're running a lot
you might suffer from runners knees or
you know tennis elbow if you're
playing a lot of tennis so whether
you're super athletic
and really into health or you're
constantly
behind your desk aches and pains that's
inherent to your life
and stress well you know it's it's
inherent to everybody's life that's okay
these elements are okay it's not about
eliminating them
and it's not about numbing them it's
understanding what these are
from the guest right and understanding
that these
are messages your body is sending you
asking you to pay attention and actually
if you are more in tune with your own
body
then possibly you won't reach a point
where you need medical
solutions for an actual medical
problem it's understanding that these
are not medical problems they're
lifestyle inherent
and so holy me comes in for these for
these kinds of solutions
offering an alternative for
lifestyle inherent stresses aches and
pains that are completely healthy
highly effective with absolutely no side
effects completely transparent
and encouraging people to beyond using
healthy
remedies and products really understand
their bodies differently
so you know we have like a bone which is
certified organic
it only has pure potent botanicals
it's clinically tested for its efficacy
um
and it's something that we encourage
people to use
for aches and pains um because it's
saying
you know that that part of your body
that's telling you okay i'm in pain
rather than reaching for your painkiller
automatically
and numbing that give your body the
attention it is
asking you to give and take a little bit
of this
completely natural completely
transparent
absolutely not medicinal product and
apply it there and just that act
actually of just giving attention to the
area of concern is extremely helpful
now combine that with very effective
botanical natural solutions
you're you're treating yourself better
you know and it's all about that so we
have you know
bath salts which is about taking the
time
to recover for your muscles post
exercise
we have cbd drops as food supplements
that's really to like
soothe body and mind when you're under a
lot of stress
um and and everything we're going to do
was going to have that sort of
concept behind it so speaking of that
relief bomb i have to hear the story
about how you
you got actually the ceo of unilever to
try it on pre-production
i i haven't heard that story yeah i love
that story
uh but i i mean it really goes to say
that
paul paul man is an incredible human
um so i've always admired paul paulman's
leadership
you know being the first
person to really make up sustainability
of business strategy and leading by
example when it comes to
um business uh acting responsibly and
understanding our impact on the planet
i think he was really at the forefront
of all that which seems like a
no-brainer today
but he's the one who's made that
the case from the get-go um so at the
time
my boyfriend was studying at insaad
um he was doing his mba at insaad and he
was in the singapore
campus and i had gone to visit him and
by pure
chance he was looking at his emails and
reading one out loud which you know just
the insead campus would
share like seminars conferences of
people coming and talking
to the students and he's like oh paul
paulman is coming to give a conference
a talk this this week and i'm like paul
pullman
unilever paul fallman and he's like yeah
and i was like can i please get a seat
can i please come
and i'm so glad i insisted and we did
went
obviously the seminar room's packed got
people on the
on the actual stairs there's no more
room anyway
and as as expected paul poman gave a
wonderful talk
and everyone was literally shaken
with a sense of responsibility at the
end of this we were all like
what are we doing with our lives we need
to save the world
um anyway and and the the organizers had
said from the beginning you know
we're gonna have a class after there
will be time for questions but then
everybody needs to leave because you
know we can't
keep people inside the room and
everything and i was like this is my
chance
i'm not i'm not giving it up and so at
the end of the seminar i left my jacket
my bag everything i ran
to paul palmer and i was like hi like
i'm a female founder doing you know
alternative remedies for everyday
stresses aches and pains
all natural um completely sustainable
um and uh and you know i just wanted to
say hi and whatever and he was like
funny you should say that i just got off
a really long flight and my back hurts
and at the time my formula because i
used it for my mom i had it and i'd been
testing it with people
so holding me was just a thought but i
was sort of testing the
formula with people so i had a bomb in
my bag i was like hang in there and i
ran to my bag and got him the ball and i
was like
i'd love for you to have that and just
try it and if it can ask you how you got
on with it
um he just told me his email address and
then i followed up
and he was incredible he gave us a
testimony
uh a testimonial of how the bomb really
helped his back
and he connected us with the ceo of
leaver ventures so the very first person
i met
and and i had like in my pitch deck uh
paul paulman's testimonial which made
fundraising so
much easier for us
wow that is that is just that is just
amazing and i think it really embodies
you know that that's like true
entrepreneurship it's not about
just you know the growing company but
it's about you know like leveraging
those circumstances
and just you know breaking the rules and
breaking the barriers and i think that's
just that
that's very very inspiring tell me a
little bit about this the market and
where we're headed in terms of
you know natural sustainable remedies uh
versus you know
you know just more medication so what's
what's because it does feel like there's
this trend you know
i think that in that trend we're talking
about you know going natural also with
food
and sustainability i think that falls
under a similar category
and and it feels that we're moving more
and more there is is this really where
we're headed as a you know as a society
that eventually just things will be
natural and
we're really just you know starting to
see this scratching the surface of it
i think that the more um access to
information
people have the more conscious decisions
they make
and this shift as you say in market
behavior towards more
organic more sustainable more natural
alternative remedies for
well-being is really driven by
millennials like healthy millennials
that the millennials are the
uh the population the generation that
spends the most on
health than any generation we have ever
had before
and they rate health the second most
important thing
in their life just after family
so it's this generation who has
a lot of access to information that are
the drivers of this shift in the market
that we see
and i think it is a lot about
the access to information and the fact
that
you you know they're more willing from
the research they make
to test things and witness the efficacy
and be therefore a little bit more
skeptical
towards you know this huge
pharmaceutical
lobbying sort of cloud that has
been stemmed from the lab
for such a long time you know for such a
long time you had such a big skepticism
around natural remedies at all with
people being like oh
if it's herbal natural it doesn't work
um
which is also a fascinating concept
that anyone would be so powerful to make
people believe that because
where do you think medicine even comes
from it comes from nature
um so it's it's fascinating that they
had this kind of power
and and they're extremely strong at it
you know the
pharmaceutical space right they won't
allow
well like non-pharmaceutical space to
talk about
anything that could be medical or
medicinal
right um even at holy me we were caught
at the very beginning being like you're
making
medicinal claims it sounds like you are
a medicine um and we're completely
natural and we're not
and we weren't trying to be i mean it
was okay we just have to change a few
wordings and you have to be extremely
careful
right um but i think despite the
limitations
despite their influence and the huge
budgets they have to do that
people have access to information and
when you have that you change your
behavior
um and if you witness the effects of
that change
in your behavior then this the word
spreads you know
um so i i do think we're going in that
direction
i'm not at all suggesting you know just
for the record
that i'm against pharmaceutical labs or
medicine
or anything like that not at all thank
god we have that and it's
wonderful and they will keep evolving
and being and doing tremendous things
and by all means if you have a medical
condition seek
medical treatment of course but it's
more than that
it's a holistic approach to health that
we want to encourage
to maximize your chances of recovery but
also
for things that are not medicinal you
don't need
medical attention it's really starting
to to separate those two
anxieties stress aches pains that
are in juice from your lifestyle that's
not a medical condition
and a painkiller from a pharmaceutical
lab with medicinal content
even though it's over the counter and
readily available that doesn't mean it's
completely safe
and so you know it's trying to
people's behavior towards a healthier
approach to lifestyle
i love that celine thank you for sharing
with me this this industry
and that i don't think nearly enough
about and i really think that i should
and i'm always excited to learn about
these different things that you know
while they may not yet be in the
forefront of
of you know what i what i do i think
that you know just opening up to this
idea
and obviously now the next time that i
experience some kind of pain i
i know intuitively and you know for i
guess thousands of years that
you know we tend to go immediately to
medicine and now without
these alternatives i'm extremely excited
about about where it said it and i i'm
extremely excited about what you're
doing with holding me
and we didn't even talk about you know
the hair thinning you know things that i
really need for myself so
we're going to take this offline and
because i need some advice on that front
a good thing
this is a very frontal interview but
before we leave i have to ask you the
most important question
uh which i i don't prepare nearly enough
for but it's still a really fun one
which is three words that either you
would use to describe yourself or if i
ask
anybody that uses or knows holy me how
would they describe selenavari
um i would be powerfully caring
very caring okay um
ambitious and determined i love it
powerfully caring ambitious and
determined
celine thank you very very much best of
luck with me and everything else you're
going to be doing
and thank you for making a positive
impact on the world that's wonderful
thank you very much thanks for your time
it was a pleasure
of course thank you
you